il est l'une des révélations de la
nouvelle Assemblée ces envolés lyrique
l'ont fait remarquer dans l'hémicycle et
pourtant mon invité se définit comme un
techno plutôt timide
[Musique]
bonjour Jean-Philippe Tanguy bonjour
Monsieur Eric alors les Français vous
ont découvert à l'occasion d'un discours
que vous avez prononcé vers les 5 heures
du matin c'était après une longue nuit
de séance qui était consacrée au texte
sur le pouvoir d'achat avec ce moment
qui est devenu célèbre alors alors alors
silence
alors
[Applaudissements]
à vous monsieur
parmi nous
collègues de gauche s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
un peu de légèreté
alors c'est un moment un peu inattendu
on va dire on a vu que ça fait beaucoup
rire Marine Le Pen mais pas seulement on
a vu la présidente de séance qui
rigolait aussi mais quand vous vous
mettez dans cet état est-ce que vous ne
risquez pas le bon mot de trop celui qui
pourrait vous conduire au dérapage on a
l'impression que vous êtes un peu en
roue libre en fait
oui c'est pas faux je vais pas vous
mentir en vous disant que c'était tout
organisé nous étions très fatigué après
je pense que l'humour le recul sur
soi-même permet de se sortir de ces
situations
compliquées voilà c'était une
improvisation totale puisque je ne vais
pas faire l'explication de vote Marine
Le Pen oui et pour différentes raisons
notamment la tension qui avait dans
l'hémicycle l'heure qu'il était elle m'a
demandé de la remplacer et donc c'était
une improvisation et en fait là où vous
avez raison c'est que aussi de
l'extérieur on entend pas à quel point
c'était bruyant et à quel point c'est
une fournaise
l'Assemblée nationale donc on comprend
pas toujours pourquoi je suis je suis
obligé de dire cela mais sincèrement si
on avait le son on entendait on
comprendrait encore mieux pourquoi je
l'ai dit mais les Français ont bien
compris parce que elle va surprise
d'ailleurs parce que j'étais assez
inquiet en fait de la façon
je n'ai eu presque que sincèrement des
retours positifs parce que en fait les
Français c'était vraiment exaspéré de
l'attitude de la nupesse bon et sur les
retraites je me suis retenu de leur dire
alors ce qu'on voit aussi dans cet
extrait de prise de parole c'est un peu
votre sens du spectacle le plaisir que
vous prenez à prendre la parole dans
l'hémicycle mais vous n'êtes pas
toujours été comme ça au contraire vous
avez dû faire un travail sur vous-même
pour en arriver là c'est ça a été oui
moi je trouve que ça se voit encore en
fait c'est gentil comme dit que que
comment dire que ça se passe bien moi je
sens toujours je déteste me regarder
d'ailleurs le le voilà j'ai eu beaucoup
de mal à parler j'ai encore des
difficultés d'élocution alors on dit que
non mais moi je les sens une par une
vous avez travaillé là-dessus depuis
très longtemps depuis presque mon
enfance moi je suis quelqu'un de très
timide pour pas dire plus dans mon coin
je me fais vraiment violence pour pour
prendre la parole et c'est toujours je
parle d'ailleurs très vite là je fais un
effort énorme pour parler parce que oui
mais il faut quand même que les gens
comprennent ils comprennent parce que si
je parlais de ma façon naturelle
j'aurais du mal à dialoguer avec vous et
en fait j'ai tendance à parler très vite
pour dire très vite ce que j'ai à dire
pour retourner pour évacuer quoi solide
si on remonte à votre adolescence il y a
un événement qui m'a étonné c'est la
façon dont vous êtes arrivés au lycée
Henri IV à Paris vous avez grandi à
Bures-sur-Yvette vous avez été élevé par
votre mère dans un milieu plutôt modeste
vous étiez pas vraiment programmé pour
arriver dans ce type d'établissement
est-ce que vous diriez que vous avez
forcé le destin en quelque sorte ah oui
ça c'est à mon oui oui façon toute ma
scolarité a été une épreuve
avec vraiment le système de reproduction
des élites alors c'est aussi des
rencontres les fait deux grands
rencontres des opportunités des chats
c'est ma prof de piano dont les ailes
qui vous a parlé du Lycée Henri dont les
filles étaient il y avait des
prédispositions donc elles avaient été
placées Henri IV et donc a pris
l'existence de ce lycée comment vous
êtes arrivés là alors racontez j'ai
envoyé et avec mon meilleur ami qui est
toujours mon meilleur ami qui je dois
beaucoup aussi dans le parcours dans la
confiance aussi qui lui a permis d'avoir
en moi-même durant toutes ces années bon
on s'est dit on va envoyer notre notre
dossier on l'a fait de candidature mais
sans en parler sans en parler à mes
parents mes parents ne voulaient pas que
j'aille Henri IV il ne voulait pas que
je quitte
dur sur Yvette pour des raisons
comment dire affectueuses il pensait que
c'était trop difficile qu'il fallait
prendre tous les matins le RER qui que
je n'y arriverai pas d'ailleurs j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal arrivé
donc voilà c'est vrai que s'extraire
j'aime pas trop ce mot il y a pas
d'autres mots là que je trouve à brûle
pourpoint s'extraire de son milieu
rompre avec le destin qui a été écrit
par la sociologie ou autre c'est très
difficile et je vais le dire d'autant
plus qu'aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
encore plus difficile s'il y avait 16
ans aujourd'hui je n'aurai pas le
parcours que j'ai eu dans votre parcours
après le bac vous avez intégré s'inspire
mais vous avez quitté cette école
d'officier supérieur très très
rapidement pourquoi oui bah j'ai vite
senti que c'était pas ma place tout
simplement c'était pas du tout contre
l'armée c'était pas du tout contre les
officiers qui m'ont accueilli mais
c'était j'ai un gros problème de
discipline de manière générale mais là
en particulier on m'a fait sentir que je
devais mieux faire d'autres études donc
je suis allé après en école de commerce
et vous avez servi la France autrement
vous avez fait les sexes en 2012 vous
commencez un stage chez General Electric
France au côté de la patronne de
l'époque Clara gueymar vous expliquer
que c'est là que le déclic de votre
engagement en politique c'est fait en
lien avec le dossier Alstom qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé exactement c'est très
compliqué à expliquer parce
qu'effectivement de l'extérieur mon
poste était très modeste les stagiaires
puis apprentis si je suis pressé avec
vous sur les sur les trois les presque
trois années que j'ai passé là-bas c'est
surtout que j'ai assisté à la direction
d'une grande multinationale et après la
crise de 2008 à un changement d'attitude
de General Electric est devenu une
entreprise prédatrice contre les
intérêts français et donc vous êtes
confronté tout simplement la réalité
très vous avez eu accès à des
informations sur le projet de rachat de
la branche énergie d'Alstom par General
Electric France
vous auriez pu être lanceur d'alerte
certains vous ont reproché d'ailleurs
d'avoir un peu inventé un rôle de
lanceur d'alerte c'est vrai
vous avez transmis des documents quand
même au ministère de l'Économie pour
pour dire ce que vous saviez de ce
dossier oui de toute façon je l'ai dit
en commission d'enquête parlementaire
récemment alors pas sincèrement parce
que je ne le suis pas mais j'ai dit vous
pouvez le faire oui j'ai essayé
d'alerter d'ailleurs c'est aussi le le
comment dire le début de mon engagement
pour Monsieur Dupont-Aignan parce que
moi il pourra en témoigner j'ai parlé à
Monsieur du poignant de ce qui se
passait je lui écris une lettre je lui
en ai parlé et après j'ai essayé
d'alerter mais c'est intéressant ce que
vous dites sur les lanceurs d'alerte
parce que en France il y a les lanceurs
sont très maltraités on est toujours fou
paranoïaque complotiste on n'est pas
reconnu on n'est pas protégé donc c'est
aussi c'est ça qui vous a dissuadé
d'aller au bout de la démarche je vais
essayer d'aller au bout de la démarche
mais vous avez transporté document à
Arnaud Montebourg qui était
collaborateurs à l'époque Monsieur
dupoignant mord organisé un rendez-vous
avec un de ses collaborateurs il a eu
accès aux informations oui et il y a
jamais eu de retour voilà bon vous savez
bon c'est très compliqué parce que c'est
vraiment une très douloureux parce que
quand vous savez quelque chose va
arriver que vous essayez d'alerter vos
mails au moyen parce que faut voir aussi
le même pas David contre Goliath là
c'est ça n'a rien à voir comme force et
après on vous fait le reproche si vous
voulez de pas avoir réussi à aller au
bout de votre démarche mais qu'est-ce
que je pouvais faire de plus la moi
toutes les personnes alors que j'ai
rencontré que je pouvais alerter je l'ai
fait moi après je n'étais je n'étais
qu'un modeste voilà collaborateur et en
plus il y a le mépris de classe et c'est
très important il y a le mépris de
classe aussi en France et que voilà le
fait d'être stagiaire ou apprenti vous
discrédit de ce que vous dites bah non
si vous étiez à un endroit qui vous a
permis de tout voir que vous soyez
stagiaire ou cadre supérieur vous voyez
les mêmes choses c'est à ce moment-là en
2012 vous l'évoquez que vous engagez aux
côtés de Nicolas Dupont-Aignan vous avez
travaillé à ses côtés pendant 8 ans
est-ce que vous diriez que c'était une
bonne école de la politique pour vous ah
oui sincèrement bon des différents avec
Nicolas dupuyant sur la stratégie du
camp national popul de liste mais c'est
un excellent et Luc local il a une
maîtrise de la capacité à faire naître
pardon un lien de confiance entre ces
administrés et lui qui unique il a très
bien géré hier après et c'est aussi un
élu courageux ça pendant des années il a
défendu une ligne nous on n'est pas
d'accord sur la stratégie mais sur le
fond moi je ne renie absolument rien de
ces années pendant longtemps vous avez
combattu le RN à ses côtés après vous
avez essayé de vous rapprocher avec lui
du RN ça a pas fonctionné et vous vous
êtes parti qu'est-ce qui a rendu se
rapprochement possible à vos yeux
politiquesment ah bah c'est très simple
c'est le fait que Marine Le Pen est
définitivement rompu en l'excluant
Jean-Marie Le Pen alors non c'était ça
qui vous vous bloquez
tout le camp gaulliste que ce soit
monsieur du poignant ou les forces les
électeurs qui pouvaient se reconnaître
dans les valeurs qu'on portait qui
représentaient comme un an 5% de la
population c'était pas la personne de
Jean-Marie Le Pen évidemment c'est pas
une question de personne c'était les
provocations qu'il avait les
déclarations condamnables et condamnées
qu'il avait faite qui pour nous non
seulement était pas nos valeurs mais en
plus empêcher d'arriver à la victoire
donc vous Marine Le Pen et le courage de
le faire et celui très peu je trouve que
vraiment le système est très dur avec
elle parce que encore aujourd'hui on le
reprend cela alors qu'elle a fait et
tout ce qu'elle devait faire c'est un
peu considéré comme le bras droit de
Marine Le Pen aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
oui mais il y a plusieurs il y a
Sébastien Chenu il y en a d'autres il y
a leur planète il y a plusieurs
personnes mais oui mais bon et puis moi
je suis je travaille beaucoup sur les
questions économies finances et c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu beaucoup de textes au
début de mandat qui ont été sur ces
sujets là et puis bon moi j'ai une
volonté voilà moi la chose que je
partage et là où je suis au service de
Marine Le Pen c'est qu'elle en a une
volonté de gagner pour sauver notre pays
et donc moi c'est vrai que j'ai un
sentiment d'urgence si vous voulez de
plus je suis petit l'urgence qu'il faut
absolument gagner le plus rapidement
possible pour éviter les fondement alors
vous avez fait partie du mouvement gay
libre qui avait été lancé par Sébastien
Chenu quand il était encore à l'UMP il y
a quelques années en 2013 vous avez
participé
manifestation en faveur du mariage gay
vous êtes gay vous l'avez toujours
assumé est-ce que vous en faites un
sujet politique moi je pense qu'on ne
peut pas ne pas en faire un sujet
politique alors il faut pas lui donner
une place centrale mais quand vous
appartenez minorité quelle qu'elle soit
vous ressentez forcément les choses
d'une manière différente vous vivez les
choses d'une manière différente vous
avez un rapport avec la nation en tout
cas pour ma part qui est très différent
mais qui je pense très partager parmi
les homosexuels français la nation est
forcément plus protectrice elle est
forcément elle joue forcément un rôle
dans votre idéal de vie qui est
différent est-ce que c'est dans ce sens
que vous avez posté ce message en 2018
c'était après avoir participé à la Gay
Pride fier de m'engueuler avec ceux qui
n'ont pas encore compris que notre
bonheur honorait l'âme nationale
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par notre
bonheur au nord la National nous avons
je pense beaucoup de chance d'être
français et de vivre dans un pays
ou même s'il y a eu des moments
extrêmement douloureux grosso modo par
rapport à d'autres civilisations et
d'autres pays le mot sexualité était
relativement toléré depuis quelques
années en plus de la tolérance nous
avons le droit au bonheur familial nous
avons le droit à avoir une vie normale
nous avons cette tolérance à
l'homosexualité n'a pas toujours été
présente dans votre propre famille
politique vous en avez même été victime
à un moment non enfin j'ai été victime
d'une agression au couteau en 2019 de la
part de groupuscule d'extrême droite qui
sont complètement dingues voilà bon et
d'ailleurs l'agression homophobe alors
l'objectif était en fait soi-disant de
révéler des choses sur mon téléphone sur
ma sexualité où il y avait rien à
révéler d'ailleurs bon on pourrait tous
ceux qui se posaient des questions leur
réponse voilà bon mais je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous c'est une question
qui traverse les familles politiques
acclameus spéciales
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on le voit bien
Marine Le Pen et la championne des
libertés publiques le vote des
homosexuels majoritairement se porte
vers elle et quand vous regardez par
exemple la gauche les groupes de gauche
il y a extrêmement peu de députés qui se
revendiquent homosexuels ça devient un
problème dans une part de la société
française qui n'est pas celle sans doute
que certains commentateurs attendaient
donc on va passer à notre quiz à présent
je vous explique le principe je commence
une phrase et c'est à vous de la
compléter c'est bon on y va je vais
essayer être gay ORL c'est
comme si vous étiez hétérosexuel pas ça
ne change absolument rien je n'ai pas
été élu président de la commission des
finances mais mais je le serais
peut-être la prochaine fois sera la
bonne non je ne sais pas mais mais je
vais vous dire allez vous surprendre
mais Eric Coquerel fait un bon travail
quand je prends la parole dans
l'hémicycle ce que j'aime avant tout
c'est des formes des idées tout
simplement très bien bah écoutez merci
beaucoup Merci à VOUS Jean-Philippe
Tanguay d'être venu dans la politique
[Musique]